j'avais à peine 18 ans et je tombé sur
un type mais horrible qui devant tout le
monde m'a foutu et de la fiche en me
disant mais qu'est ce que tu comptes
faire dans ce métier avec avec ta gueule
avec ta excès de peau comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais une peau un peu comment dire une
vilaine peau et j'avais des boutons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle d'un dans mes premiers
castings en fait j'étais arrivé à paris
et gt gt je faisais des petits boulots
pour pour pour essayer de faire les
cours de théâtre et j'ai jamais été en
parallèle je faisais déjà couru les
castings pour essayer de commencer à
travailler et j'étais un casting c'est
vrai que j'avais j'avais à peine 18 ans
et j'avais une peau un peu comment dire
une vilaine peau le borgne et j'avais
des boutons et je suis tombé sur un type
mais horrible qui devant tout le monde
m'a foutu et affiche en me disant mais
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire dans ce
métier avec avec ta gueule avec ta avec
cette peau comme ça et je me revois je
vous assure qu'en vous en parlons là je
me revois sur le trottoir en train de
repartir est en train de repenser à
assat ce type quoi en me disant mais
comment comment on peut dire ça comme ça
aussi facilement devant devant plein de
gens et en fait et en fait c'est
finalement ça se trouve imams il m'a
aidé sûrement parce que ça m'a donné
encore plus la rage de de trouver a
confiance en moi parce que je pense que
si j'ai fait ce métier ou si c'est parce
que j'avais pas confiance en moi parce
que j'avais je m'en empêcher quelque
part comme le personnage que je joue
dans le film je m'en empêchait être
heureux et je pense que on fait tout ce
métier quelques bars qu'on cherche une
reconnaissance on cherche le regard de
l'autre en fait est que et du coup
peut-être ça m'a encore plus aidé
heureusement ça n'a pas détruit parce
que je pense que ça ça surement
détruites d'autres personnes se dépasser
c'est c'est de ne jamais renoncer en
fait c'est de ne jamais renoncer et de
de ne pas se laisser abattre et
d'accepter
l'échec mais c'est de se dire que que
tout est nécessaire en fait que tout est
nécessaire et que et transformer le
labeur par le plaisir en fait et et
essayer d'approcher en fait le plaisir
que ces deux d'assouvir ses rêves est en
fait d'aller le plus loin possible